what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are continuing our story on
Batman the white knight and I'm glad you
guys are really enjoying this I'm glad
you guys are really really diggin the
white knight because if it is such an
amazing story it's crazy the next comic
book convention that Shaun Murphy goes
to I want to sit down and just be like
alright dude how did you come up with
this idea I want to just like have a
conversation with a guy and just be like
man I will buy you lunch and just tell
me how you came up with this idea
because this is this is awesome like I
really really want to do that God this
story is so cool okay so here's the
thing
Batman the white knight cuz I was
talking a comic story about this and and
it was one of those things where I
didn't really occur to me until I was
reading it but it is very much a
political story but the cool thing about
this is that it's a political story done
in a really really good way because what
it does is it creates kind of a unifying
factor with readers as opposed to like a
political story that focuses on race
relations more so than anything else
basically we have Jack Napier who's kind
of running the show like Jack Napier
who's basically elevated himself to
prominence in in Gotham City after
having quote-unquote cast off the Joker
identity but the cool thing about this
is that within the realm of Gotham City
within this whole area you have back
port and back port is largely where core
african-americans reside at and so with
Jack Napier showing up here initially it
does kind of put on the play of it being
like a sort of race-based story like a
racial political story and this is that
Jack Napier has appealed to the or black
parts of society that live inside of
Gotham City but where Duke Thomas is
kind of like the the speaker for this
part of Gotham City for backport it is
cool because he basically says look like
the cops never come out here we're kind
of just left to our own devices to try
to make sure that things don't get too
terrible the cops are never really out
here the wealthy never come out here
Batman only ever comes out here to
remind us of our place to make sure that
we don't get too far out of our little
pocket of the city but no one ever
really cares about what happens to
backport and then Jack Napier came here
with no security he came here with no
cops no escort nor nothin it was Jack
Napier and Harley Quinn who just came
walking into back port that right there
is brazen enough because it's kind of
like look we could be killed at any
point just because of the fact that
we're politicians and were perceived as
part of the wealthy elite that are out
there were enemies of backport more or
less but walking in there is a sign of
Solace because it's like look we
realized we're putting our life on the
line walking in the back port but that's
the risk we're taking because we want to
make this part of Gotham a better place
and that's what Jack Napier has been
doing he came there to build a library
he's been helping to improve the youth
center like he's been gaining the trust
of Duke Thomas over the course of the
time that he's been there and Rena been
working within back port and because
he's gained the trust of Duke Thomas and
everyone in back port trust Duke it
means now they trust Jack Napier Jack
Napier in turn basically uses this
moment to announce his candidacy as a
councilman in Gotham City and this is
where Shawn Murphy initially kind of
Dell's into the idea of like racial
issues and then immediately jumps to the
bigger picture and says okay now it's a
social class issue because throughout
the story the entire time we learned
about things like the Batman Fund the
sense that you have Batman who goes into
a part of town things get destroyed the
value of that property plummets the
wealthy buy it the government uses the
the batman neo destruction fund or
whatever it is to rebuild that area and
then the wealthy sell it for top dollar
they basically profit off of Batman's
actions and the the criminal element of
Gotham City when you have Jack Napier
who steps in and who in turn says like
this issue stretches all across the city
of Gotham subtly it's not a racial thing
anymore because poverty is race neutral
and if you're Jack Napier and you can
walk in to the city of Gotham if you can
turn over a new leaf and then say I want
to fix the city of Gotham and I want to
do it by getting rid of all the
corruption by making Gotham a better
place by starting with the poor and
making your lives better
you've just won an entire social class
it's Jack Napier winning Gotham City not
by force as the Joker but through
politics is Jack Napier so from here you
basically have him like leading a March
and that's when all this really kind of
kind of begins to take off and it really
hits home with the idea that like Jack
Napier is really gonna do this you know
he starts is having people marching in
different directions the cops are going
to respond and then Batman intervenes
and keeps things from getting out of
control but Batman is already viewed in
a sour perspective by the city of
backport so for everyone watching this
for everyone out there for everybody in
in backport who's watching this event
unfold everybody who's watching from TV
what they see is this back port is a
city that has been historically
oppressed within the realm of Gotham
poor black Americans live there Batman
is routinely sent there to keep them in
check the wealthy and the powerful
profiteer off the struggle of people in
back port and then when as soon as you
have a person who crops up and says
let's make this part of the city a
better place Batman comes swooping in
you know that's how people see it they
basically see it as like this system
working against us that people are
backport and they don't care
politician runs for and recognizing
what's going on here Jack Napier tells
everyone to stand down so there's
another everybody stand down and Ronnie
chill relax calm down
I'll go willingly suddenly he's the good
guy he's the guy who saved back port and
that's exactly what happened it picks up
with Gotham insider and they basically
say like we thought there was gonna be
another riot and back port but Jack
Napier swoops in and saves the day when
the press wins social media when the
people in the city and who cares what
the wealthy and the powerful want to do
because they're powerless in the face of
millions of people who don't want them
there and could just drag them into the
streets and shoot them if they wanted to
so again it's cool it's such a twist on
the character of the Joker now from here
we pick up with Jack Napier meeting with
Commissioner Gordon I remember
Commissioner Gordon has been the one cop
who's been on the fence he's been the
man on the wall in the Gotham police
department not in the sense that he's
like the only guy out there keeping
things afloat but in the sense that like
he's the one who's not really sure what
direction to go in because rumor at
Commissioner Gordon has always basically
been a good guy he's done some
questionable things but he's usually
always been a good guy he was the guy
who said look we don't necessarily like
the idea of a vigilante in Gotham but we
do realize that we need Batman because
he's willing to do things that we as
cops can't do but Commissioner Gordon
has always been on the fence about
Batman and he's always been on the fence
about his role as a police commissioner
and the corruption in Gotham City and
Jack Napier plays on that but him
showing up and talking about the Batman
devastation fun and things like that he
says look I want to use this
Commissioner Gordon's initial responses
yeah but like you literally use that as
a talking point against us to reveal
Tubac point the fact that the wealthy
and the powerful were profiteering off
back port whenever you know crime took
place and the value of parts of the city
plummeted like you've used this as a
weapon against us and now you want to
use it for yourself but Jack neighbors
response is but it's not selfishness I'm
not using it as like a slush fund to
just kind of pay you guys off the point
of the Batman deficit a devastation fund
is to remodel it and rework it into
something called the Gotham terror
oppression unit basically what this is
designed to do is to take the vigilante
element of Batman Batgirl and Nightwing
bring them together and unify them
alongside the best cops on the surface
if we see like Gotham terrorism
oppression unit my initial thought is
Jack Napier creating a secret police but
the way that he introduces this is it's
not like that it's basically taking the
vigilante element of Gotham and instead
of having it operate without any
accountability and no oh
like Batman Batgirl and Nightwing do two
pair them up with cost to make sure
there is oversight and there's checks
and balances the good cops would keep
the vigil of vigilantes in check and the
unit as a whole will be able to reach
into parts of Gotham City's that cops
can't normally access and bring various
criminals to justice it's an exceedingly
great idea the argument that Jack Napier
makes here is look you say you need
Batman and that's fine but what you
actually need are Batman's resources if
the resources of Batman were available
to you as the Gotham police department
can you honestly say you would not be
better equipped to face off against the
the super criminals that exist inside
this city and so from here what we do is
we pick up with the whole idea of Lady
Joker or or Joker or I'm sorry neo Joker
if that's what you want to call it but
remember in the last video what we ended
up finding out is that where Joker was
using the mind-control device of the Mad
Hatter to control the various criminals
in Gotham City in order to basically set
up a ruse so that he could infiltrate
the offices of Mayor Hill and then learn
about the Batman devastation fund and so
on and so forth that a lady Joker had
essentially co-opted that technology
stolen it overridden it and took control
away from Jack Napier and so it means
she's now in control of the criminal
element of Gotham City in its entirety
and they're just running through and
they're ripping everything up in its
entirety now the whole idea behind this
is it again much like the Joker himself
it's a ruse it's designed for the
purpose of allowing her and in Mad
Hatter to get inside of the Gotham City
Police Department and then find some
some personal files some information
this being kept hidden by either Jack
Napier or the Gotham City PD itself
discover what those files are actually
you know access them and then go through
and do whatever it is they're gonna do
with them but the other cool thing to
you is that in the aftermath of this
huge event you have Batman and you have
Commissioner Gordon who sort of get into
an argument here and this is where Shaun
Murphy basically tells us Jack Napier's
won over Commissioner Gordon piece by
piece
Gotham's just being broken apart where
Commissioner Gordon is just like Jack
Napier is right if we had your
technology at our disposal Gotham City
could be a better place it could be
adequately protected and Jack Napier has
that plan I don't even know what your
name is
I don't even know who you aren't all I
know is that you're a guy who runs
around Gotham City in the middle of the
night dressed as a bat beating up people
and I've trusted you up to this point
because you've done what needed to be
done you've brought in the bad guys and
so on and so forth but what we have now
is a man who's shown up here with a
concrete solid
verifiable and trustable plan on how to
make Gotham City better and there's no
reason not to trust it
essentially Commissioner Gordon kind of
makes this argument I like Batman you
are becoming unnecessary now we now have
this guy Jack Napier who's willing to
work with us as opposed to alongside us
and then in turn make Gotham City a
better place we don't have to blindly
trust him and so at this point we
basically pick up with Jack Napier in
Harley Quinn who were getting together
you know kind of kind of coming off of
you know touching naughty bits and
ultimately they're met with the arrival
of neo Joker and this is of course when
we basically find out neo Joker was the
Harley Quinn at the beginning of the
story before the real Harley Quinn
showed up so she's basically fake Harley
but for the sake of this video we'll
just call her lady Joker going forward
just there's no real confusion but the
coolest element of this of this whole
story really comes to play and we
actually learn about her origin we
basically figure this out when when we
end up having her meet or I guess return
back to the Mad Hatter and the reason
why she ended up leaving Jack Napier and
and the original Harley Quinn is because
she basically says the only way for me
to actually win you back the only way
for me to get the Joker to come back is
for me to take over Gotham City because
the Joker's ego is too intense to allow
somebody else to win and so because of
this she goes through and tells this
huge origin story and she essentially
says that like she was a person who cut
herself she was struggling with all
kinds of anxiety issues and depressive
issues and so on and she was in the
process of actually just kind of ending
her own life and then what do you know
The Joker busts into the bank and the
Joker starts robbing the joint but as
soon as the Joker put a gun to her head
she wanted to live and so in response to
this the Joker's started calling her
Harley and so she played along now this
is kind of interesting here under normal
circumstances we would expect a story
almost identical to like the original
Harley Quinn instead she's just kind of
well depending on how you look at it in
the right place at the right time or the
wrong place at the wrong time
but because Joker starts calling her
Harley she plays along under the hopes
that Joker will let her live that Joker
won't kill her
but then because of the fact that she
looked so much like the original Harley
the Joker took her back to his hideout
gave her a Harley Quinn outfit never
touched her except for - except for - no
to bandage your wounds and that's it but
she basically became the new Harley
Quinn in the eye - the Joker she was the
new Harley now this is so cool because
what this does and what this indicates
here is the Joker's not nearly as
cold-hearted as we would expect but
expect to believe he is but virtually
every depiction of the Joker going
forward from like crisis on Infinite
Earths to the modern day has always
given us this version of the Joker where
he's effectively a person who needs
things he's like a child crying out he
needs the Batman because the Batman
makes him complete
what this indicates is he needs Harley
Quinn the Joker's incomplete without
Harley Quinn if Harley Quinn was really
that irrelevant to the Joker if he
really cared that little about her then
there would be no reason for him to
replace her but the fact that the Joker
goes through all these steps to make
this chick the new Harley Quinn
indicates that even if it's only on the
subconscious level he's created a new
Harley and that's why this works because
this girl Mary Andrews she fell in love
with him The Joker completed her gave
her a reason to live because she's in
such a place where she needs to belong
and because the Joker's in such a place
where he needs a Harley Quinn that who
fall in love it's wild
but picking back up with with Jack
Napier in them what we end up having is
Jack Napier and Commissioner Gordon
along with maybe a couple of the cops
who basically put on the bat-signal
Batman doesn't actually show up instead
which who shows up is Nightwing and
Barbara Gordon Batgirl and this is when
Commissioner Gordon and Jack maybe
you're saying we just want to speak to
You Tube we don't want to talk to Batman
and so what happens is Jack Napier goes
through and spills the beans about the
Gotham terrorists you know tear his
outfit and says like this is what we're
shooting for three billion dollars a
year is what the Batman devastation Fund
was pulling in we're reworking it and in
turn what we're gonna do is we're gonna
start outfitting cars to start creating
our own Batmobiles and you guys are each
gonna get one we want you on board we
want you as a part of this now remember
the whole reason why Jack Napier does
this is because Barbara Gordon will
listen to her father she'll go along
with him Dick Grayson will go along with
her and Batman will likely go along with
the two of them especially if he feels
like he's left out the cool thing about
this is remember Batman is very much a
wild card in these instances you can't
guarantee Batman will go along with them
and so ultimately what we end up doing
is picking up with the data files that
Lady Joker and Mad Hatter were sifting
through and what we start to do is find
out a handful of things one of which is
that a lot of the files that are going
on in the Gotham police department have
to do with Victor freeze that Victor
freeze was a Nazi that his father served
in the SS that what's going on here
is that despite all those things the
wealthiest and really the most powerful
family in Gotham City at the time the
Wayne's Thomas and Martha were meeting
with Victor freeze and what this
indicates is that Batman's own parents
had some pretty seedy dealings with some
pretty unsavory individuals that existed
inside of Gotham City but with that
being said guys we're to go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to Commons explain make sure
you guys said the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
you